AROUND THE TRAFFIC.
GOOD POINT THERE.
TALKING ABOUT BUSINESSES.
LISTEN, IF YOU ARE A BUSINESS
OWNER ACROSS AMERICA YOU KNOW
THE STORY BETTER THAN ANYONE.
>> Dana: WENT THROUGH THE
WRINGER.
>> Bill: A FEW OTHERS WHO HAVE
DONE IT AS WELL.
LISTEN HERE.
>> THIS IS JUST A SLOW BLEED.
WE HAVE 100% OF THE BILLS WITH
33% OCCUPANCY.
NO ONE IS COMING BACK TO THE
GYM.
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS DONE HIS JOB
AND HIS JOB IS TO KEEP PEOPLE
FEARFUL OF THE ONE THING THAT
CAN HELP THEM.
ACTUALLY GETTING FIT AND
STAYING HEALTHY.
>> Bill: THAT MAN THERE WAS GYM
OWNER FROM OCTOBER OF 2020.
TRYING TO KEEP HIS BUSINESS
ALIVE AND NEW YORK GOVERNOR'S
LOCKDOWN.
FAST FORWARD A FEW MONTHS LATER
AND NOW THE STATE GYMS ARE BACK
TO FULL CAPACITY.
BUT ARE THINGS LOOKING BETTER?
CHARLES CASSARA IS WITH US
TODAY IN MANHATTAN.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
ARE YOU BACK?
>> WE'RE BACK IN THE TECHNICAL
SENSE THAT WE'RE ALLOWED TO BE
100% CAPACITY.
MASKS ARE COMING OFF BUT AS FAR
AS GETTING PEOPLE TO COME BACK
THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU HEAR FROM
THEM?
FEARFUL TO COME BACK OR JUST
GET OUT OF THE HABIT?
>> THEY RELEASED A NEW CDC
GUIDELINES AND GOVERNOR CUOMO
DID ADOPT THEM INTO SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT THERE IS A LOT
OF DIFFERENT CAVEATS WITH THEM.
IN ORDER FOR US TO GET RID OF
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING INSIDE OF
OUR GYM WE HAVE TO TAKE
PEOPLE'S VACCINATION CARDS.
THIS IS CREATING A BIG PROBLEM
BETWEEN PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT
TO GIVE IT OR HAVE BEEN VAC
NAITD.
A LOT OF GYM OWNERS LOST
ANOTHER 5 TO 10% OF THEIR
OVERALL BUSINESS.
IF YOU DON'T TAKE IT THEN WE
CAN HAVE THE MASKS OFF BUT WE
HAVE TO KEEP SOCIAL DISTANCE.
IF WE'LL KEEP SOCIAL DISTANCE
100% CAPACITY IS PREDICATED ON
THE SIX FEET.
SO THAT DOESN'T WORK.
HOW DO WE GAIN ANY PROFIT?
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I WAS SURPRISED BY AND
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO KNOW
THIS GYMS WERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
PPP LOANS.
>> A LOT OF GYMS ARE GENERALLY
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE IN THE CITY
HERE BOUTIQUE ORIENTATED.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
EMPLOYEES.
THEY DIDN'T APPLY OR GET ANY
PPP MONEY.
AND THAT WAS A BIG PROBLEM IN
OUR INDUSTRY.
PLUS WE ALSO KNOW IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES IT WAS RIDDLED
WITH FRAUD.
INSTEAD OF FIXING IT WE JUST
PUT MORE MONEY BACK INTO A
PROGRAM THAT DIDN'T WORK AND
ALSO KNOW BANKS GAVE PRIVILEGE
TO THEIR LARGER COMPANIES THAT
WERE WITH THEM.
SO WE TEND TO 1099 A LOT OF
EMPLOYEES OR TAKE PROFIT SHARE
CHECKS, BOTH OF WHICH WE CAN'T
APPLY FOR THE PPP.
SINCE BEING CLOSED IN MARCH TO
BEING OPEN IN SEPTEMBER,
LANDLORDS WANTED MONEY, RENT
WAS DUE.
WE GOT NOTHING.
>> Bill: WE SAW YOU FROM SEVEN
MONTHS AGO.
NOW SEVEN MONTHS LATER AND
HOPING FOR MORE OPTIMISM.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU ARE
COMING FROM.
YOU SUED THE GOVERNOR OF NEW
YORK TO REOPEN.
>> WE BANDED TOGETHER AND GOT A
LOT OF GYMS TOGETHER SINCE WE
WEREN'T CONSIDERED AN ESSENTIAL
BUSINESS EVEN THOUGH WE THINK
WE ARE.
WE GOT TOGETHER AND SUED
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S RULES WERE ARBITRARY
AND OVER THE COURSE OF TIME IT
PROVED THAT WE WERE RIGHT AND
RIGHT BEFORE WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO GO TO COURT THE GOVERNOR WAS
SUPPOSED TO SHOW CAUSE AND
DISCOVERY, THEY OPENED US.
NO ONE KNEW WE WERE BEING
OPENED.
NOT THE MAYOR, NOT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH OR THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT, NO ONE
KNEW BECAUSE OVER THE WEEKEND
THEY KNEW THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COME TO COURT.
THEY SHOULDN'T SHOW CAUSE, NO
PROOF FOR SHUTTING US DOWN.
NONE OF THE SCIENCE TO PROVE IT
AND THEY OPENED US UP.
>> Dana: WE'RE HERE ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL DAY.
PEOPLE ARE OUTSIDE AND GO TO
THE BEACH THEY MIGHT THINK I
NEED TO GET BACK TO THE GYM.
WHAT IS YOUR PITCH TO GET
PEOPLE TO COME BACK?
>> OUR PITCH HAS ALWAYS BEEN WE
WERE THE ONE INDUSTRY THAT
SHOULD HAVE STAYED OPEN BECAUSE
YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM IS WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT PROTECTING
YOURSELF FROM COVID.
YES, THE VACCINE AND IF YOU
WANT TO GET IT THAT'S GREAT AND
THAT'S THE WAY TO GO.
BUT YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM.
WHO CAN DO THAT?
THAT'S THE GYMS.
IF EVERYBODY HAS BEEN LOCKED
DOWN AND WANTED TO GET BACK
INTO FITNESS, FIND A GYM THAT
IS WILLING TO ACCOMMODATE YOU
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOUR STANCE
IS AND LET'S START TO GET BACK
AND HELP THEM OUT.
>> Bill: YOU TALKED ABOUT
STAYING HEALTHY IN OCTOBER.
SO MANY PEOPLE, WE CAN RELATE
TO THIS ABOUT TRYING TO KEEP
YOURSELF IN LINE.
>> WE FIGHT AGAINST OBESITY
WHICH NOBODY WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT.
WE FIGHT AGAINST HYPERTENSION
AND DIABETES AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT WERE MAIN CONTRIBUTORS
TOWARD PEOPLE DYING FROM COVID.
>> Dana: GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
LIKE TO STAY IN TOUCH AND SEE
HOW IT GOES AND EVERYBODY GET
BACK TO THE GYM AND TAKE